Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Little Nightmares.
Now we just escaped from the "prison,"
which it only seemed like it was a prison - for little kids.
And why is music starting up right now??
And why is this staircase so huge??
And also this is the staircase from the opening menu of the game.
Ohh hello now hi- I'm gonna go up here first now I'm gonna risk falling down into the chasm below,
because it's want to do that recently but-
Oh hi....!
Ooohh, what do we have here?
Sorry, okay.
What am I looking at? Is that a pile of dead bodies?!
For all I know it could be a pile of dead bodies-
Oh didn't make it there
hyeeee huu.. ooooo
No, can't deal with that.
Anything up here?
Man, I really don't know what all the easter eggs are for and that's what I could only assume
are the like, small little things. That I'm- like the knick knacks and the dolls.
I don't know what I'm supposed to be doing with them,
except casting them--
HEY! Hyuayy
Hi.
Hello.
Why did that move?
Is there something in there?
Hello??
Okay I assume it's nothing-
and why is everything stretched upwards?!
That doesn't make any sense!
And I think I need this to flip that switch over there.
Maybe I can take that jug of booze and drink my sorrows away.
Oooh secret hatch. Okay.
Huyueyy
Oh.
*Random noises*
Uh...okay??
I have a funny feeling we're either underwater, or we are currently-
Oh boy
we're currently--oh I guess I could do that-
Oh a key! Good- good for me!
We're either underwater or we're on a boat. I'm kinda leading towards a boat right now because it's very swing swongy- HIIYYA
No-
NO!
I meant to grab the light but I don't know why I thought I could do that!
Ooohhhh.
Ohh hi.
I didn't think I could open this- and oh my god that is a painting on the wall.
I'm not gonna say if it's good or bad just in case I'm insulting someone but it's--it's definitely a painting.
So the key goes over there. So that's important to remember... I think.
Huahhhh--kerchunkles
And then so long as I'm able to get up here-
Again..Why? Why does that happen?
What is with the rumblies?
Okay. But either way we're not gonna try to jump on the light like a stupid idiot and then we're gonna actually go the way it wants me to go.
Which is over here *Rando noise* then down here, *Another rando noise* then grab the key.
and then we're good to go I think anyway.
*boink*
grab---GRAB IT!!
GRAABBB IT!
don't you not grab it yo--WHY!?
why would you just chuck it off the way. Don't be so rude
Alright so we gotta put this in the key.. or the lock I guess the key goes in the lock and I know what words to say when I'm supposed to say them.
annnd habooski
Huahh
Alright, then we grab that, and then I guess we just shove it in there.
For whatever reason, this giant ass key-
I don't know if I need this
but I can pick it up, take it with me I guess just to hide my trail.
haa
Okay, nevermind then just gonna set it down gent--wait..
Was there something up there?
Hello? Nah, can't get up there but it looked like there might've been
HOIIIIYAaa
Hello?
Ooooohhhhh
That's a nice monkey...
ooohhhhhhh good
okayy??
I don't know what I'm supposed to do about that,
but maybe do I need this monkey for something else?
Can I drag this over there maybe?
I know it wants me to hit this button but I don't know if I'm gonna be able to.
I need someone bigger and stronger to be able to do this for me.
Alright whatever I'm gonna take this with me because apparently maybe I'll need this.
I don't know why I'd need this I just- I'm just suspecting that I might need this.
*weird moan*
Okay. Oh no.. Oh don't do that.
Don't do that, just don't do that
whoa
oh
ooohhhh!!  I can throw it real good because of this.
oh c'mon don't throw it like that.
throw it harder, throw it harder!
Haaaboski!
oh- Oh!
*Odd noise*
For some reason I thought that was gonna go BAM right on top of my head
Ima take you with me. You're useful.
See, you gotta hold the button down to make it throw longer.
Which is good I suppose and I'm suppose to do this.
Haaaabooski
Nailed it, naailed it
Im gonna crawl in here because I think there's gonna be something comin' after me.
You never know, when there's gonna be something else coming in the elevator.
That wants to kill me very very very VERY dead
Or maybe eat me up I don't know
Cuz I don't know why they keep people in cages, why would they keep little children--
--such as ME--
in cages?
Or maybe not even me, maybe I'm vermin compared to all of these giants
maybe I'm just itty bitty worthless vermin to be stepped upon
I know not, how could I know? Maybe I'm a fully grown--
*coughing*
*Stomach rumbles*
Huh?
Wha-?
What happening? Wait hang on, I need to see something here
Ok, I just needed to see if it was gonna blast me
Or suck me in and chop me up
Alright, yea monkey- Oh god..
What is going on? I can't be starving already I just had a bite to eat.
Ya know I just think there's something wrong with me
Unless I absolutely just need food-- Oh no....
Oh no
OH noo...
Uh noo
Imma have to--
Imma have to eat that rat, aren't I?
OH nuh..
Ooh no
Imma have to eat that rat
..Oh no
*Stomach growls* Oooohh nooo I see a rat hanging there
Right down theeeere
Ooooooh noooooo
I'm not doing so good
Good thing I brough this monkey with me
Ooooooooh nooooooooo
OOOOooh nooooo
Oh, oh good I don't have to eat the rat
The gigantoid rat, but there's meat in here and this is a trap--
This is very clearly a trap!
I'm just gonna ya know-Just gonna ya know grab this
Just for company in this, uh, cage here
Imma make sure that I'm, uh, not alone
Hih-eeeh
No, c'mon you can get in, you can get in there
Ehh.
Yea, you're gonna join me in this trap
Can I--Can I--Can I eat this?
Am I gonna-Am I gonna...Am I gon-There we go!
Oh-- No no n- There we go!
Nom nom nom
Oh....You wouldn't judge me, would you?
Mandle and the monkey!!
Oh... OKAY!
I knew it was a trap
Good ol' Mildred the monkey is gonna keep me company in here
OH WHERE'D MILDRED GO!!???
WHERE'D MANDELO GO-- Oh god
Ohhh
Why!?
Why are you doing this?
Why is this a thing you do?
Why? Just why? Imma-Imma poor-Imma poor child....maybe
Oh no..
Like why would they keep me in cages, huh? Oh- oh ow
Ow, OW!
OW OW Okay I need to go this way, huh OW yea OW
Well shit dude he probably heard that
But maybe I can get one of these other guys outta here?
Or maybe there's something over here- Oh..
Oh very nice
Come with me little one, I'm not gonna help you or nothing-Yea you stay huddled in a heap I guess
You're still alive I think- but..All hope has been lost
Looooong ago, okay here we go
*Weird Mark noises* There we go, alright
And then, hahh
Alright
And if I let that go? Uh, okay so that's a problem so I need something to be able to keep that open
That's probably gonna be over here
Oh good at least I--Well shit didn't mean to do that but can I..?
Oh! Oh well that's handy.
I can carry this lantern with me, have I always been able to do that- Oh well that doesn't help anybody at all...
Alrighty then- Weellll Imma do my best here
I don't know whyyy I did this here but..ok?
Can't carry that with me, maybe I'm just gonna toss this into the abyss
Is that a good idea or a bad idea?
Ill go with the bad but here we go anyway
Welp! See ya!
See ya buddy! Glad I did that
That's gonna bode well when it explodes all the methane down at the bottom here..
Ok, so what I gotta do is I gotta find a way
Can I use any of these? No? Okay
So I gotta find either a way to climb up these things
Maybe there's something at the top that can help me or
Oor, oooohhh
*Weird mark moany sounds*
Is it climb up-able? Neevermiind! That was all a bulllshitt
Alright fine then. Come with meeee
And you'll seee!
A world of pure imagination-OH!
I can swing-swong
And then using my momentum when I let go
I'll be flung in the elevator and then I won't have to-ah
I already know what's up man, I already know what's up
You think I don't know what is UP MY CRANKY CREW-aaaaahhhh~
uhahaha~
uhahaha~ Enchanté. -Is this a way to go?
What's goin on...
Where am I now?
Uhh, can I pull on this pipe? No...
Uhh, can I pull on these? No...
Uhhh...
Well, this seems awfully problematic.
I'm in a room...
With nothing inside of it. I can't climb on this...
I ca- Ohh! I can climb on this apparently! Oh.
Oh, good.
Man, I am just an agile little shit.
Aren't I?
Creakity creaky, no one's gonna notice this.
Sneaky peeky creaky creaky! Can I light that? I bet I can.
Is that a guillotine?
Why?
Wh-why?
Why is there a guillotine there?
I don't know if I like that very much...
Ohh god.
Okay. Eeh.
Is that something to worry about?
Ohhh hi!
Oh hello!
Don't you freaking dare.
Alright. Here we go!
Oh-what are you doing? What are you doing??
You're not--You didn't see nothing
Nnnnaayyyyyy!
Haaaaaahh-Oh over here oh over no
Sneaky peeky OOhh oh my god
Oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
Ooh no oh no I didn't do something right
Uh oh uh oh uh oh uh oh uh oh
Oooohh no oooohhhhh no NO
Uhh...I've been grabbed
Oh I guess it didn't kill me but okayyy... Alrighty then
*Mark chuckles*
I don't know what to make of that but i saw the CRANK that I need to put in the CREW
Then I'll know what to do, but maybe if I sneak..
Maybe if I oh, so gentl-What are you doing?
What in the world are you doing? No nononONONONONOnononononononoNOno
Oh it's blind
Oh my god it doesn't matter if I'm quiet anyway, it's blind
Oh my god, that's crazy
So if I put that in there- Woah woahwoahwoah WoahwoahwoahWOahwoahwoah
Haaaaaaaabooski
Uh oh. Uhohuhohuhoh. Uh-
Oh...It's sniffing the smells
Eeh. Ah fuck! It's sniffing the smells, so it can only smell, it's blind.
And it can hear I guess, so if I keep stanky things around me or I lead it to stanky things then, maybe just maybe, I can misguide it
And that'll help me-Uhh, and then they're just put on meat hooks like that
I mean thats messed up man, that's messed up
How do you smell that? Do I smell like fresh meat or something??
I don't know what that's about, but apparently this
has gotta go in the thing
grab it, grab it, any day now, nope
Oh well, you can just make
a few passes of errors
okay you can drop it too that's also an option
I don't know whyyyyy he's not going for me NOW
Uh oh!    WELL
What is up my CRANKY-CREW I AM OUTTA HERE
WHAT CAN YOU DO ABOUT IT
HO I can't believe that worked
Okay I'm gonna GO before he Grabs me because I think he can still
grab me from up there
with his LOOONG RAH-ARMS
rhmmm smack mm
Nope nope, don't like that, don't like that at all
Don't like that at all, and I don't know why
he didn't go for me that time but I think I lucked out there
and I didn't have to do the thing that I was supposed to do
Which is BAD because then I didn't LEARN
how to do the thing that I was supposed to do
I think it was something about the stanky shoes
which I believe are the shoes of the children that he's
Probab- Oh my God
Oh no...
oh my god
Holy shit
This is like, uh, this is like
the, um,
the Holocaust Museum exhibit
just the shoes.
From the concentration camps just the- the shoes, and what that represents just-
That's horrifying.
OOH! What is that?! That's even more horrifying! Ah! Ah! Go up on that thing!
What in the fucking hell?!
There's a Shoe Monster?!
Really?!
There's a shoe monster?!
Ah!
Oh- OH HEY! G-G-G- Get up- Get up- Get up the damn thing!
Why won't you get up when I tell you to get up?! I'm telling ya what to do you just gotta do it!
Ya just gotta do it!
I swear to gash, I'm telling it what to do.
Okay, come on, okay.
So I- I think jumping in this is a fruitless venture. So I'm just gonna try to grab, there we go it just grab; ya just gotta grab it.
Ha-ba-ba boopy!
Okay, that's what it is and that's what I'll do. Oh yes, my Crankiest Crew!
Ah yeah, jumping is a fruitless venture, jumping is a fruitless venture! Okay!
Hop! There we go! You frick off you stupid, creepy Shoe Monster!
Excuse my- ?
What now?
Oh!
I'm back where I am! I was before I got captured, I recognized the rat there.
Eh...
Alright, let's carry on I guess. Ah, Okay!
Hi, alright then, I'm gonna keep going!
Oh no, why do you need to be here and why do you need to do that you creepy bastard?!
No! No! NO!
No no no, none of that, none of that.
Eh!
He'll never find me in here!
He'll never find me, uh oh he's gonna find me!
Hah gah! I'm around stinky shoes man!
Oh okay.
Oh!
Alright then.
Yeah, not there ya big dumb idiot!
Oh, oh not there ei- No
Up, yeah! That's more like it, yeah. Yeah pretty much, yeah I'm pretty much exactly there ya s- s- oh my god, stop moving your face like that ya weirdo.
It's like his fa-?
Oh! Go get it, go get it! Go get em'!
Uh, it's like his face it-
Esh! It's like his face is peeled down, from the top of his head down around his eyes. That's-
That's really weird
Why, if that is true, either he's wearing a mask or his face is peeled down around his face?
Oh, hello friend!
Oh!
Barry Manilow the Monkey! Why did that move?
Why?
Uh, I don't- I don't- I don't- I don't like that.
I don't like that, I'mma put you back in the toybox I guess?
Nope, that didn't work.
Move this?
Okay?
Oh! Barry no!
I left Mr. Mabaloo!
I left Mr. Magoo the Monkey up there!
*Mad Mark*
Okay, you can't smell me down here, can you?
God, you- you have weird, short stumpy legs? Did you suck all the length of your legs and I'm guessing dong area,
And insert it into your hands? Oh! It's Mildred! Oh hi, Micheal, how ya doing?
Oh, Matthew the- I see Matthew up too there's tons of em'!
Good thing I was giving them a whole bunch of names, because, they are not unique.
What are they doing?
Yes that is a spoon Mr. Salad Fingers, congratulations - you found the spoon
Wheare am I going ?
Uh so we - Look !
His face is just like peeled down
Why ?
Uhhhh
It's so gross
Oh my god it's another porcelain doll
Why ?
Why are these down here and why -
*glass breaking*
Oh!
Oh I was supposed to break those with something in there ?
We - I-I don't know !
I don't that was what I was supposed to do
Alright then, I broke that so, good, maybe - I-I guess
Alright!
Oh he's gone so
uh, ok, um..
Mumbloo could do a ...
Help me out here I don't - *lost Markimoo*
I don't know what I'm suppose to do
Oh boy
Ah
Oh I see
Mmm
So I think I'm suppose to climb back up
here
when he's in the other room
Maybe
oh no!
I'm just supposed to be here
no no no - ohhh no no no no
Ya miss me uh ? - Ah dummy you missed me
You stupid idiot
You stupid dumb -no, no, no
NO !!
I was near - uh don't crack your neck like that
I think I know what I need to do, I need to THROW one of the monkey DOWN and it's gonna make a lot of noi-iu-suh
And he's going to be distracted
By said noises
and he's not gonna know where I am
Cuz he's only go smell, his good old sniffer-snoofer
And he's got his ears
So I need to take this
Take -take this
Ha-boozki !
Yea
Yeah yeah yeah, you go for that one don't ya ?
Go, go buddy
go go go
You over there, oh that's good
And then I need to
Ok and then - oh!
NOOOO !
why did he -
Why did he kept me then ?
Alright I got to figure this out because - again I got through the other place with a whole lot of luck
Maybe I should just throw the monkey and get the fudji out of there
because it's obviouly making more noise than I am so
might be a better idea
Yeah so there is carpet
and I think that is fundamentally important
*throwing noise*
So I gotta stay on the carpet
cause he can't hear
Yeah
That's it, that's it, that's it, that's it !
You can't hear nothing
you didn't hear NOTHING
Oh that is it, I got this, I got this
Can I push this -oh
I'm gonna push this out in the way.
Oh I was hoping it's was gonna fall and get a big old crash,
but no such luck is mine today.
But that's good. Okay so it's
calm, carpet, and cool headedness
that's gonna win the day.
Also, crack cocaine, lots of that.
Get the 5Cs in there: Cool, Calm, Cool Headedness...
...Crack Cocaine. Got it. 5Cs.
Oh. HhoooOOOOoowww did you get there?
IiiIIIIsss there more than one of you?
[softly] Okay stay on the carpet, s– that's carpet.
It's Cool, Carpet, Calm,
Cal–Cool–Cool–Carpet–
[louder] Calm, Carpet, Cool Headedness, Crack Cocaine.
Squeeak, squoonk, squeaak, squoonk.
Squeaak, squooonk.
Why are there so many nooses on all these clocks, by the way?
Is that supposed to be symbolism here or is there something else going on?
[door and clock crash loudly]
Well, that was quiet!
Glad I did that. I'm gonna just be over here now.
Don't worry about it, dude.
Don't worry about it, ma dude.
Don't worry about it, ma dude!
I thought I told you to not worry about it, ma duUUuude?!
'Righty, then.
I'm assuming that it's all fine–
[clock makes weird noise]
Maybe it's fine.
Seems like it might be fine.
Uh oh.
Okay, yeah, un– oh!
[clock makes weird noise]
Ahhh!
That's when I can move! I get it, okay, I get it!
I get it. x9
Yeah, maybe you shouldn't be in this room, ya douche! Maybe you should get the faaahhge out of it.
[clock chimes loudly]
There we go, there we go.
Freeze.
[softly] Stay calm and on the carpets, calm and on the carpets, calm and on the carpets–
Grab me a shoe, grab me a shoe, grab me a shoe,
[clock chimes]
grab me a shoe,
[loudly] throwing the shoe!
Woodibeeboop!
Sliding on the carpet, sli– AAGH!
I think I need to run now!
Cool, Calm, Collected, and Carpets, oh boy, oh boy, oh boy, oh boy.
Yeah, you don't know where I am, ya douche, do ya?
Uh oh. Oh, slip through here maybe.
C'mon, slip through– there we go.
Woo!
A blooks! :D
What am I supposed to do about these books?
Am I supposed to... climb up them?
I don't know.
You can almost see my eyes from here. I think I see my hair.
Alrighty, then.
Yup! Okay this is working.
Yeah, this definitely isn't dangerous- wwhhhyyy??
MMMmmm-wwwhhyyy??
Boop!
Why is that a thing?
Can I open this? No? Good.
I can climb these.
Good ol' bookshelf. More than just learning.
Ugh.
Can I make it over that lip– yes, I can. Okay, alright, gonna light this and then
jump like a BOSS!
Blank blenk!
Yeah, yeah, that's good.
Oh, hi. Okay, here we go.
Huee–ehheehh!
Ugh, why does this feel so weird?
Everything about this entire world is so distorted.
OOoohh, hi.
How do you move around?
How does any of this make sense to you?
You're blind!
Ugh, I don't understand.
Okay, I need to find another cranky-yanker.
So wherever there may be a cranky-yanker that's where I'm gonna go.
Oh, he's patrolling.
Oh boy. Can I climb on this– yes, I can, indeed.
Okay, up this.
I see another candid light down there, but I don't know if it's gonna do me any good.
Just gonna assume
everything's honky-dory.
So I need to knock these down, maybe?
[Janitor growls]
Uehh.
Grab that.
HIIYYAAAA!
Hiyyaa! Blap!
You like that? You like that?
I'm breaking all your shit just as vengeance for you being a dick.
Agh, that's not what I meant to do.
No, no, no, noo!
Yeah, how do you like them–
APPLES! Agh, frick my dick...
Mmm'kay, alright.
Okay. Oh, that was a longer jump than I wanted it to be.
Jump.
Aha! Didn't make a peep, now did we? Now, this is how it's supposed to be, ya douche!
Finally makin' our way downtown, walking fast, faces passed and I'm home-bound– oh.
Bamanabamana...
Okay. So, I gotta go all the way back, don't I?
That's gonna be a problem.
C-Can-Can you...
[TV starts playing]
'Kay. Come on in here.
I know how this is gonna work.
Aahhhhhh, yeah.
Weird how that TV just magically turned on, huh?
No, no! No, no, no, no, no.
[Janitor growls]
No! No! How did you know?!
What?
Okay, c'mon, mooOOoove faster please.
Oh god, oh god, don't get in my way!
Whoa, my god.
Alright, okay, that was way too close. I thought I was done for.
Beebidibabidiboo x3, screw you!
Okay, put that in there. Put that in there!
I don't think I have time for this, but here we go, apparently!
Can you not– oh! Where did he go?!
He disappeared into another dermension...
... apparently. Or he went invisdible.
It also could be an option– Hoip!
Alrighty, then. Good hoip.
FffloOOpty!
Alright. Okay. Good floopty.
Alright, and we made it! Where are we now?
Where is this? I don't like this.
I don't like this! But here we go, apparently.
Maybe I shouldn't be on this side of this thing, but I'm gonna...
Yeah, I think I need to be on the other side, there's gotta be a...
... handle on the other side too. 'Cause that's steam.
That steam looks bad.
Deadly, almost.
Probably gonna kill me, y'know?
Aaaannndd...
Oh, yeah.
That's nice. Can you jump? There we go.
No, no, no. No, no, no. There we go.
So I'mma take you with me 'cause I'm pretty sure I still need ya.
I probably could have jumped through the other way– I didn't even need to do that; I could have
jumped over the gap!
Huh.
Ohh, I did need it. I did, ah.
I did need it. I'm a smarty, I'm a smarty.
Ah! There we go.
WHOA!
HHhhhhoooo...
Screw you. Okay, I see how you be.
And again.
Where are we and who built this place?
That's an even more important question than, "Where are we?"
No, probably not. But it's also a very important question.
Who built this place? What kind of engineering principles did they use?
What kind of standards? Did they do any standards?
Is anything here by protocol?
I think not.
So I'm just gonna go a little bit further here and figure out what's what here.
Okay, I guess... through here maybe? Can I slip through? No, okay.
Hey!
Oooww?
Well, alright then! I guess that's the end for me!
Thank you for that.
I had no warning and then Death approached faster than I could react.
So, I'm gonna end this episode here. I'm all out of time. But I am loving this game so far.
It's such a weird mystery. It's such a weird game.
A, like, period.
But it's such an interesting mystery of,
"Why?"
And I like it!
I like the question "why?" because it's a universe that is  here and obviously every character is just there, but–
Why is it all happening??
Whyy?? But either way,
thank you, everybody, so much for watching.
Thank you, everybody, so much for letting me know how this game is in the comments below.
And as always, I will see you...
... in the next video!
Buh-bye!